welcome back to gamespot at e3 2016 and
I am very happy to be happy happy happy
happy hoppity hop that's how happy I am
dhanak I cannot wait to talk to you
watch dogs too we you are executive
producer I don't see your producer and
producer and he worked on the first game
as well yep wonderful I very excited to
talk to you and we were talking briefly
before we went live that the first game
it was a game that I think a lot of
anticipation behind and and some people
thought that it felt sort of short of
the the quality threshold is that we
were sort of hoping that game would be
what was it like after the first watch
what was the mood like and I mean there
is the old adage and nobody knows more
about what worked or didn't work with a
game than the people who made it so what
did you guys feel after watch dogs came
in well after five years on it they were
happy to kind of ship it yeah yeah I'm
back you know especially with the new IP
everybody's going to expect something
from a game that might differ from what
you're actually doing for sure
ultimately it was interesting to get
player feedback a lot of people love the
game and also got some feedback of some
things people wanted to see improved and
we agree with most of those so that's
the good news is it's not like it
diverged the feedback diverged from what
we wanted to do so we took that to heart
and we definitely worked on the things
that people feedback about on the sequel
yeah i mean just initially seeing
footage of watch exudes in the trailer I
mean there if there was a laundry list
of things that you think you might
change about it it looks like you were
tackling them head-on you have a new
protagonist the world looks incredibly
well realized what were some of the
things that you guys wanted to change
for watch dogs too yeah so one of the
things we wanted to have a lighter tone
obviously the wanted like change the
setting and right from the get-go we
chose to go to the San Francisco Bay
which has by itself in its sunny
California it's an open heart light
hearted area so we got that vibe from
the setting and then we built a new
character that was from the bay so you
know he's he's grown up in Oakland he's
got that eclectic you know open-minded
spirit of San Francisco and then he's
got the smarts and the creative side of
the Silicon Valley all brought into one
character so that was one big change we
took a lot of risks and making all those
changes yeah but actually it really
helped us to push the game forward
and then it was hacking we needed to
make hacking more important more central
to the game and that's what we put all
our efforts in for the gameplay let's
talk about the Bay Area first of all I
live in Oakland that when I moved to San
Francisco I lived there for your
previously it actually felt like a video
game town because it has all of these
like disparate but like connected but
very unique neighborhoods all over it
it's almost surprising nobody's decided
to do it before yeah to be honest it's
one of the first decisions we took and
when we started thinking of San
Francisco or like no we can't just why
can't we do San Francisco a terrific
place perfect driving beautiful vistas
yeah there's so much diversity from non
neighborhood to another and then what
other city has like a bridge and then
when you go on the other side of the
bridge there's a big Natural Preserve
right yeah except for the sitting right
there exactly that's all the things we
wanted all like together and then
obviously with hacking and technology
and big data being central to automatics
right having Silicon Valley and all the
tech revolution in and all the big tech
companies set up there that was even
more interesting for us so how big is
that Barry I mean I heard it was
Sausalito is in it yeah what's on the
East Bay's it just Oakland is there
Berkeley like what a minute yeah so so
we went from a small marrying section
with Sausalito we have Oakland but we
didn't go beyond Oakland and then we
have San Francisco obviously and in
Silicon Valley we kind of scaled it down
tremendously it's a bit of a theme park
so yeah Valley to be honest but we kept
like Stanford and we brought in like San
Mateo and we brought in a lot of the
iconic places that people what I think
will enjoy seeing I do you have people
on the development team who are natives
of the area who sort of helped you
figure out some of the stuff cuz it's
quite complicated but it's story of the
bear it is so yeah so we foster the
people who come from the Bay Area on
Arthur steinborn they keep us real and
we're also lucky because we have we have
a development studio there and in San
Francisco so we're getting working back
getting feedback from our colleagues
there we have them played a game try to
find our houses and drive around and
then it's testing our layout for you
well it's going well on that front are
the game spot or twitch or I GN offices
you're all around the same area yeah one
Street basically and well you can check
it out when you get with you I mean the
Ubisoft office is right there as well
yeah we're having fun with that good
stuff and sort of today I know you're
obviously going for a lighter tone here
but you know the story of the bay area
and especially when an african-american
protagonist I mean you cannot talk about
San Francisco and Oakland without
talking about race issues and also most
certainly gentrification are you dipping
into that at all so the reality is as
we're looking at a system a computer
system surveillance system that do
automated profiling on people writing on
a lot of those subjects so you know you
can be profiled because if your gender
your raise your revenues where you live
but also what you post it on maybe
social media five years ago and so we're
touching on all those topics and yeah
gentrification is also a topic we're
touching on you know it's interesting
now to see that people who make pretty
good money are being pushed out of San
Francisco's I said yeah just a poor
being pushed up and so those are all
subjects that tie into what we're doing
really what we're trying to do is to
build stories are that are grounded in
what's happening right now on the bay
obviously we push you know bring it up a
few notches with really corrupted
establishment yeah don't exist in the
real world we hope but but in in the in
the heart of things we're trying to tie
it up in stories and content that people
are hearing in the media is all the time
and when you finished on watch dogs one
that you always know that the second
game wouldn't be Aiden Pearce said you
did you know you would you choose
somebody else almost Grand Theft Auto
style going in no you know we it wasn't
predefined we thought about it the
reality is it's interesting to have a
character that's grounded in your
setting so we knew we wanted to change
setting and then it didn't feel like
Eden fitted in California right yeah you
had a tragic personal story yeah yeah
it's film noir personality yet which
fitted in our rendition of Chicago and
what we wanted to do there to magically
but what we wanted to do it watch like
sue is a lot lighter in tone for sure
we're dealing with serious topic but we
don't want to take ourselves seriously
you know because people spend some time
a hundred hours in open world games you
don't want to be you know rooting for a
hundred hours yeah fair enough add
there's a sort of look what looks like a
Donald Trump reference there as well oh
you made that link i did yeah so in that
mission we're actually going to try to
get evidence that a politician is using
and what is working with social media to
rig the election basically trying to
manipulate people through social media
in a nut to lidgett way to get his way
and yet voted into office and this
mission obviously it's it's a sort of
you know it's happening around this area
do the missions and watchdog to do they
spill out into the sort of wider are
there like you know
instances in buildings which then spill
into car chases or that are sort of
happening in the open world they're not
just in specific buildings yeah and it's
a big thing we wanted to do in watch x 1
sometimes we forced a certain play style
like now it's going to be a chase
mission a try to chase okay we're trying
to avoid that so we're creating a goal
and then we're trying to create system
that will surprise the players so if you
play a mission maybe your target ends up
fleeing and it transforms into a car
chase in the city but maybe in my case I
get what I want you never even noticed
so there was no car chase yeah so it's
moving more toward a free approach free
planning for the player and give him the
tool to figure out how he wants to do
the mission instead of us kind of
forcing a series of specific activity to
it and then you're also creating I mean
from what we've seen so far obviously
it's it's only been you know it's a
couple of trailers and obviously this
gameplay as well but it does really look
like the world you've created is a lot
more active and a lot more detailed than
the first watch dogs so I guess are you
going to have side missions within that
world are you do you expect the player
to just go wandering I mean for instance
you know Marin County going up there
it's all just you know wildlife you
expect people to just go around there
and explore and find things and that
much things to hack into the 100 not
really yes it turns out so okay so that
was a big thing we got feedback for and
we totally wanted to do also which is to
change the game structure for what we've
done a lot of ubisoft game have similar
structures open-world games where you
have a series of missions and when you
go from A to Z and I'll finish the game
yeah and you have activities and things
to explore in the world so instead of
doing that we have more of a quest
structure basically and what you're
trying to do is is build up a movement
to overthrow that that corrupted
establishment and you're trying to get
more and more followers so you can do
that by doing many different quests and
you can find those quests in the world
so in some ways we're breaking with the
idea of main missions and side missions
right okay what I mean you're exploring
and you'll find you'll find quests and
missions and when you do them you'll get
followers and I'll get you closer to the
end so we don't have to play through the
same missions in the same order to get
to our goal so the focus is that follow
or us exactly exactly so there are other
things you can do ligand oh no you can
do sail sail boat races obviously i'm
gonna get a lot of followers for that
for your you
movement but you know aside from those
things that just come kind of emerged
from the bay most of the missions and
quests that you can do our focus on
getting followers you're handing a lot
of responsibility over to the player a
lot of junior you're allowing them to
hack all these cars you're allowing them
to pick them the quest structure it's
quite a massive undertaking it's trying
to give them more free i mean you know
what it's actually interesting is when
you give players more freedom we also
remove some load from our own shoulder
is like right right for hacking we used
to you know we had a lot of things i'll
take an example that's is really fry you
can bring up and then we have to place
this is relief at the perfect place for
it to be useful of course now instead
you hacked this is really if you can
control it put it where you want put out
the hype you want so now well you know
we can just drop a scissor lift and the
fire figures out how he wants to use it
so in some ways by giving control to the
players it's easier mmm I'm easier in
some ways but obviously incredibly
difficult your gender or do you spent
five years walking on watch dogs you
know Austin the price and the people
watching we don't know how to make video
games watch dogs look like an incredibly
complex game to make and watch dogs to
looks even more so what's the mood like
in the office going into watchdogs to do
you feel like you've got something to
prove do you feel like maybe you've
learned a lot or is it just you know
these games are so big to make you kind
of need that second game to get it right
it's true I mean you need to build on
what you've done I mean but at the same
time it's funny because we wanted to
take risks so we wanted to you know
surprise players and refresh things but
you also want to build on what you did
right so yeah I want to start redoing
things just for jewelry doing things so
getting an extra chance to kind of build
on what you did and most of the core
creative team is the same we brought on
new people to refresh the core team but
a lot of the people are the same in
there they still have the passion to
really deliver a lot of things we've
wanted to deliver for the past six years
which is you know cool hacking control
over City and a fun open world to
explore yeah well I for one I'm very
excited for a Dominic a thank you so
much for coming on thanks for having
when is watchdogs to available on mobile
platform November 15 worldwide ps4 xbox
one pc good stuff looking forward to it
thank you for two playing my
neighborhood in and work my work commute
I can now do any video k thank you so
much pleasure and thanks for watching
folks who got loads more games coming
off tekken 7 is up in a second actually
how rad assam is going to be joining us
in a few minutes then we've got dead
rising for zelda and much more stick
around back in a few
you're watching the game spot stage
brought to you by airheads